[Music]
in model murder news oh no you can't
kill beautiful people model murder maybe
they can own model airplanes models of
doing the me yeah me the models that's
okay because the person that's yeah if
you're beautiful you can't maybe it's a
roland emmerich movie and they just
destroy the [ __ ] out of models it look
like the White House and she model mud
submitted by Shona from Scotland show no
heyy a top male model was convicted
after murdering his industry rival I'll
turn a leak my own boss you know what
I don't mind male models dying but then
kid models girl models hand models we
need what about hand male models yeah
like the more models male models that
die the higher our values exactly are
their hand male models girls for what
like if you're trying to buy a tool
driver or if they're gonna hold that to
like a door knob if they're holding a
burger you wouldn't use Bart's [ __ ] up
at the [ __ ] time that's true I
thought of by piano keys I can't have
model
I'll have woman's hands battle-scarred
yeah you could do like back to school
hand modeling they have too many
wrinkles or anything scarred whooping
this whole rivalry thing here so George
Coe he's 24 years old
Coe huh he is a British cat Walker and
he was convicted so they're a prostitute
a British cattle cuz that's what they
wrote I just pictured a hot back from
the waist up and then cat like legs I
just saw gay do with the leather leather
hat and pants and he's just going like
this on the catwalk all oh that's a
go-go dancer that's pretty big Mike
that's a that's a chip that you would
like put in your IG story no so he
Friday's be like he killed Harry
Zuka 25 years old I wonder how you
killed him
this is Harry days play detective he's
the one I hate crime now so they're
saying he is like the number one black
British male model and he killed them I
died oh he's like the most beautiful
skin I've ever seen it's [ __ ] it's
also black and white photos so you kind
of moss it's glowing but it's so even
your skin doesn't look like that in a
buckle my photo I think it's close
that's cuz he's not black have you seen
his Instagram this is what it looks like
the negative version of this you don't
follow my Instagram preserve my perfect
you never put a block away photo up I
have a picture up Steven I will do that
before this video comes out you look
like a [ __ ] idiot
this dude is the one that killed Harry
oh no wonder he's Joe he looks like a
villain - yeah he's got a scar a villain
scar goobers go back it's also not fair
one second heavily edited photo versus a
one wait a minute did you just notice
did you just notice that this is like a
high school sweater and this is a
[ __ ] blazer I saw that with the
button and stuff I thought it was two
separate [ __ ] up pictures high fashion
okay we have a beautiful model and then
we have oh well this is a head shot too
that's a head shot I think my mug shot I
mean yes sorry I'm over I was like
that's our terrible head shot at this
game mug shot yeah because I couldn't
find any of his modeling well he looks
like a war refugee and murderer but he's
got really pouty lips a nice skin and
symmetrical eyes they do look similar I
could see how that's probably one of the
best mug shots I've seen actually no
there was that one but no they're always
pretty nuts with like it's like Nick
Nolte haired like and they look
surprised
yeah always every time they have the or
they look angry the the lines in the
back to show how high they are yeah [ __ ]
yeah
I like help me messing up my hair is
just me making my hair slightly like 3%
different yeah actually looks like you
styled it looks better now right yeah oh
that's you messing it up yeah exactly
I didn't want to point that came out
better no all pointed okay thank you
like this yeah that's the [ __ ] from a
mug shot yeah my hair already looks like
mug shot it still looks pretty good
stupid Joe yours would be it would be
flat like like almost like a bowl okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's great so George
oh it was apparently really obsessed
with Harry
George's own killer Harry's the victim
Harry would claim that they sound like
1940s villains
it's [ __ ] bread names I'm telling you
the limeys have weird names over there
man what sounds I guess Chicago seeing
like George and Harry
everyone's Harry over there I swear the
vaudeville scene heavy yeah so here you
would create a look so beautiful hello
Harry Potter Harry would claim that
George was a fake and warned him to stop
being a copycat and then George came out
saying that he slept with Harry's
girlfriend and then who's also a model
so this guy was just obsessed stalker
with this guy mm-hmm that's what the
prosecutors if George was obsessed with
Harry yeah and then
so finally Harry agreed to meet up with
George especially after the whole
claiming of him sleeping with his
girlfriend you're gonna have a walk off
each other like how could it be just be
like like Zohan and have a walk off and
so head Zohan [ __ ] yeah I'm superhero
guy you don't mess with the Zohan yeah
the secret agent that does the console
console so they made they made up so
George showed up with two of his friends
if he's bigger oh and they had barbells
in their hand there were the fitness
models that was the game we're going to
[ __ ] you up
personally [ __ ] yep fitness models
yeah so then there's this video they got
an interesting entourage this is a video
of the murder of like some sort of
tussle like I don't know if that's
actual moment oh so by the way the way
that Harry died one load to the head
orange stabbed him in the heart
oh that's pretty gangster with a
stiletto heel it was red bottom so there
the the spiky Louboutins mm-hmm yeah so
you can see that they're all oh I
thought it was at a gas station like Zoo
nice so they they pointed out that they
had the dumbbells we started running
away so then yeah he serve anyway but
then at this point what I've been there
that guy got hurt huh
yeah he just got winded got tired didn't
do cardio he ends up leaving and then
this dude comes back but the point that
I'm confused is apparently like that's
the moment that he already got stabbed
but he was running maybe adrenaline oh
yeah a baby chicken yet happened they
ended up going in this little corner
here and then they were texting and yeah
and now they're all going to jail
forever
yep like give me a break man what do
they think would happen yeah that's so
ridiculous
when all of them could have continued a
life of modeling yeah a great life go to
pretty to live amongst nothing but
beautiful people on the outside so the
other two guys that were with him was
that CCTV yeah one of them oh he's not a
model for sure their fitness models are
they are they look asleep
they're not I just made it up they're
just friends
yeah but George is the one that actually
did Dan it sucks so he did it with
intent to kill right well probably maybe
sounds a little heart yeah yeah we're
just having in general right yeah yeah
here these are all your vitals you
showed up with a knife in each hand oh
[ __ ] fight luck he was Asian
like it's a kung fu movie it's an Asian
thing yeah and Harry
Oh Harry was the one that had the
dumbbell dual wielding swords you say
that
flipped it's confusing but yeah so now
they're facing or at least George he's
facing life behind bars Pam in sentence
it's crazy when people's worlds are so
small and what's important to them it's
like I gotta be the top model and it's
like i'ma kill for that [ __ ] yeah so and
then what they waste their life on it's
so stupid
yeah they're so reactionary to looks
like that girl that shot up the YouTube
headquarters yeah cuz of adsense stuff
oh yes like and she was like some but
she was already crazy yeah her channel
already saw it's probably already crazy
but I kind of world this small too but
she's been that YouTube is directly
[ __ ] her life over that's her whole
world
that's like everybody who picked on me
middle school I don't even [ __ ]
remember those people you know I mean
like I don't even know who the [ __ ] I
don't remember it gets better it gets
better right that's what everyone says I
remember I'll never forget yeah but this
dude you know when he ran away he was
trying to global and he died on the
sidewalk of it you sure you're into a
hospital do but you want to spend your
last moment like it's hospitals too far
but you don't know what's your last
moment hopefully you got stabbed in the
heart you probably didn't I try to plug
that [ __ ] you call like uber or like
call 9-1-1 or something I try to plug my
wound I'm like I gotta see my husband
one more time but right if you get
stabbed like this the holes only that
big you just hold it draw your heart's
like yeah it's not a big enough hole you
get three finger that [ __ ] George said
that Harry punched him and then went on
top of him stabbing himself that's crazy
I don't know I I think it's pretty nuts
to stab someone too I think it's well
this is the UK right so they don't maybe
I don't have guns or they do or I don't
know maybe I couldn't afford it but I
don't know but I think stabbing is a lot
more so personal yeah and there's higher
chances of like straight death if you
get stabbed multiple times that's true
if I wanted to kill someone I think
stabbing would be way more satisfying if
I grab them by the back of the neck and
I looked into the eyes and then I stab
them I'd be like god this feels so good
the cops would rather get into a
gunfight than getting into a
my knife fight like yeah or like scuffle
with someone that has a knife
[Music]